we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
why don't we go to our next caller from
the 6 5 0 area code 6 5 0 you're on
hello David Pakman yes who's this hear
me we can hear that Aaron go ahead Aaron
so I am a liberal but I
I love done and when I've noticed after
studying and looking up gun laws from
various countries mm-hmm typically in
the more you countries and including
Canada you're allowed to own ar-15 to
pistol grips and petrol magazines mm-hmm
some are state limited to 5 like Canada
but countries like France in Germany I'm
Frances 30 and Germany doesn't really
have a magazine capacity limit I wonder
how you feel about that
so here's my thought on this we can get
into very very micro debates about gun
laws across states and types of
restrictions and how they've impacted
crime compared to the background crime
rate which has decreased over time and
then account for the fact that in
Chicago even though they have strict gun
laws you can drive to Indiana and buy go
we can do all that but I think that
there's actually a bigger picture here
which is that the problem isn't just
guns it's Americans with guns right and
that's what I am increasingly learning
which is that there is something in
American culture where we are more
likely to think of a gun as a tool to go
out and quote solve problems that
shouldn't have guns involved in any way
so I think that we can slice and dice
well Switzerland has this law and when
Australia banned guns this happened and
here's what happened in Japan etc it's
not just the gun laws it's that the gun
laws need to reflect what's going on in
the culture and American culture has a
major major problem with guns so I think
that we can look at gun laws elsewhere
and and explore what changes have
happened
but ultimately the gun laws in the u.s.
need to be tailored to the culture of
the US and there's many toxic elements
of American culture with regard to guns
well I agree with you like we should
have better background check laws and
those things but um well one of the
things you mentioned Australia banning
guns there is an interesting fact I
learned in Australia there are more guns
now than they were prior to Port Arthur
okay yeah I'm not making any specific
comment for against a particular
legislation what I'm pointing out is
that the United States has a unique
problem with guns and thus the solution
is going to have to be a unique one
that's tailored to the problems of the
United States so it's gonna be more
geared towards the people then it's you
know like it's gonna be have to get
towards individual States or is it gonna
be have to do federally um how we got
tackle this problem where it's state or
federal is less the issue it's got to be
it has to be all-encompassing in terms
of dealing with both the people and the
equipment that's available but it's a
certainly a broader topic than what we
can kind of go into today but Aaron I
appreciate the call and your bringing up
a lot of good points and I know a lot of
pro-gun liberals actually and you know
very pretty common thing in Vermont and
and in some other places